there is no minimalist rule book
well until now the minimalists have
created 16
rules for living with less a free ebook
which you can download right now
at theminimalists.com resources
enjoy minimalists
do you think going back to a flip phone
and not having the temptation of your
smartphone at your fingertips all the
time
would help with the social media dilemma
and fear
of missing out this is like i keep
talking about this
why haven't i done it yet josh yeah why
haven't i gone back to a flip phone yet
i don't see the necessity for doing it
honestly yeah
what's the problem with the smartphone
stock experiment honestly is what i was
thinking
i'm fine with that yeah i think it's
fine but like i guess
my my question is what's the point
what's the diff here's a better here's a
better question
what's the difference between a flip
phone and a far
[Laughter]
and a smartphone that is stripped of the
distractions
um the difference is accessibility
if i had only a flip phone then
you would and most people if they knew i
had a flip phone they would understand
they don't have access to me
as if i had a smartphone which uh which
yeah whether it's
how so they can still text or call you
yeah um
like well i mean the difference is like
people their expectations are different
that's
so that's what it is people's
expectations whether or not you have a
flip phone or a smartphone
well no like the people who i talk to on
a regular basis they wouldn't know if i
had a footprint think about leo abelta
he has a flip phone
he used to maybe maybe he doesn't
anymore i don't think he does but maybe
he does that's my point
right but what but i know that if i
think about getting a hold of
leo that i'm in my head i'm like oh he's
got a flip phone
twitter's probably not the best way to
get a hold of him right but like
also if you have a smartphone without
twitter on it you can set that
expectation as well
yeah my point is that like if you're
talking about rendering the smartphone
into a tool the same way a flip phone
would be a tool
the question is then what is most
effective for you and then
i think you can accomplish here the
problem that i have with this experiment
is that it requires acquiring another
thing in order to simplify oh yeah yeah
no i totally agree
no you can totally you can strip the
smartphone
and make it as useless or just useful
yeah as a flip phone that's a good yeah
it's a good distinction by the way
right right or if you're going to do
this experiment i'd rather
especially since it is an experiment i i
would if i'm in your shoes
sonia i just get rid of the phone for a
week or a month
and and all together and
in doing that you will learn a lot more
about yourself and your habits and you
can bring it back in a stripped fashion
where it actually is a tool
i feel like yeah i have a question for
you do you feel like those expectations
are of yourself or the expectations that
other people have of you
because i feel like if i was to have
yeah like if i have a phone
and i know that it only has it has
certain limitations and i kind of feel
like i can't go past that limitation
so i put less pressure on myself yeah
i think it's uh i think it's probably
multifaceted i think in my head
it is my own expectations um however
i think it's the temptation of having
the smartphone
like that is what the flip oh
yes thank you for helping me clarify
this a flip phone takes away all the
temptation
and ultimately that's that's the problem
for me is
that having the smartphone i don't have
twitter on my phone
but guess what i can go to you know
safari
and i can go to twitter and check my
twitter yeah now it causes friction i
don't go to twitter nearly as often
um same thing with uh email i don't have
email on my phone but guess what i can
go to
chrome on my phone and i can totally
check my email on my phone if i have to
so i'm wondering if you could delete the
web browsers though
yeah maybe but again you're right
but the temptation that's the thing
right like having that
having that constant temptation for
example you don't have social media on
your phone
but every once in a while you want to
post something on instagram yes i have
to download the app you go download the
app yeah
you post the picture you put it back but
the because you have the option you
even though you do such a good job of
not having that on your phone like
you'll still
the temptation is still there you'll
still use the option sure
even yeah so with a flip phone like you
don't have that option of like well i'll
just download the app and
post a picture and delete it real quick
so it's it's really
um the temptation and that's what she's
talking about she's talking about having
this
smartphone at your fingertips because
that's what that is it's having
all that temptation at your fingertips
yes you could literally take everything
off the phone
except for phones and text and it would
be just as again useful or useless
as a cell phone yeah but the temptation
no matter what is still going to be
there and i got to tell you like
i am i mean i can only be tempted so
many times
before i finally give in yeah i think it
depends on like the heart like the hard
lines that you require for yourself and
i think that's that's so personal to
each individual person that like
some people like i like i appreciate
that hard line i set my phone aside and
i can forget about it too and it's nice
but it would be nice to have that
limitation and sometimes i look at that
light phone and i'm like oh that's so
cool yeah you were able to attach it and
then i don't have to change any numbers
and i have the option and screenless
saturday and
but the light phone oh yeah because it's
like a bluetooth connected thing
yeah it transfers so that your phone can
still receive calls from
yeah right again the uh the only the
only
thing i struggle with is buying a new
thing in order to simplify oh i totally
agree
with you do that don't don't isn't that
every kind of
goal of every purchase if you're trying
to simplify your life and live most
simply and effectively like
isn't that kind of the way no it
shouldn't be i mean i think we should be
able to
simplify by i think i think you would
want to
subtract by subtracting not by adding
addition by subtraction
yeah but i guess what i'm saying is
value adding like regardless
i mean if the ultimate goal is to have
yet less than yes then that wouldn't
necessarily be an alignment but if the
ultimate goal is for it to add value to
your life like we've talked about like
i feel like it's it's a tool i see what
you're saying like if i had
this orb like then it is a tool and this
orb and i was like and if you touch
this orb you're gonna have a better life
and i hand it to you and you touch it
you're like oh my god my life is better
yeah and it legitimately is then yeah
get the freaking orb
yes um life changing orb patent pending
or get access to the orb
right right yeah yeah i think that's
what i'm trying to say without needing
to consume the orb all you have to do is
touch the ore but then
you what you simply need is access to
the point i think the problem with
with couching it in in value we have to
be really careful about that because
we don't want something just because it
adds value we also have to determine the
best use of those resources totally
right
yes and so i mean i think you could do
this experiment also instead of saying
flip phone you could say landline phone
yeah um and so they're a different
version in fact
i i skew toward that so you still have a
phone yeah
but it doesn't allow me it i don't get
to keep it in my pocket when i leave the
house
you feel like you're cheating if you
were to do that like it seems to me like
like i feel like i think that ryan i
probably have more personalities that
are a little bit more like
a little bit more like bullying in china
shop and twitchy versus i think
so i think i don't think that that tool
would necessarily serve you in the same
way that it would serve
like me because for me i'm like i kind
of i i would like that hard line because
i kind of
i feel like i kind of i don't need it
but it would be helpful in the sense
that like
i know that i struggle with it so it's
kind of like when i'm doing yoga i'm
like i need a block
it sucks to have to grab a block but at
the same time i know that like if my
poses are gonna be better than
i'm going to grab it i need a block sure
like just to grab a stack of books is
not going to do it like yeah sometimes
like you need the black but
to josh's point yeah we're not
encouraging anyone
we're not we're not putting a hard line
down right now and saying
no if you buy a flip phone your life
will be better certainly so
or worse or worse yeah the the thing is
is like yeah
you don't wanna there's always a good
excuse to bring a new thing into your
life of course so you gotta be honest
with yourself and ask you if you're like
you know using the excuse or not when i
look at the flip phone
the question comes to my mind is like
but does that really eliminate the
distraction if we're trying to do is get
rid of distractions
then just get rid of the phone all
together get a landline phone
or go with no phone at all for a period
of time if you really want to eliminate
the distraction
actually get rid of it yeah because with
the thing in your pocket you still have
the texts and the phone calls and all
these other distractions and
so you have to you have to assess
whether or not that is the best route
for you